皆様こんにちは
[音楽]
山田あきひろです
和食料理店を
営んでいます
江戸時代中期
1757年に創業者料理屋です
創業265年数えると私で10代目になり
ます
店は
江戸の
創業当時
魚屋でした
二条城に
魚を持って出入りさせてもらったと聞いて
います
そこから
魚を料理してお家やお寺に配達させて
もらう仕出しという仕事を始めます
今日は若い方が多いと思いますのでもしか
すると知らんかなと思いましてこれ何か
わかるでしょうか
今はですねあの自転車でリュックサックの
ように
四角い箱で
背負ってたりしますこれ
岡持と言います
昔はこれで料理を運んでいました
この
蓋の裏にですね明治21年明治21歳と
書いてますけれども書いてますので遅く
とも
1888年には
仕出しの仕事をしていたようです
で今から60年ほど前にはお店に来て料理
を食べてもらうという料理店の仕事を始め
ています
こんな白衣を着てですねいかにも料理人と
いう
姿をしていますが今日はお料理の話は全然
しません
今日お話ししようと思っているのは人と人
とのつながりのことです
私は小学校は
京都の小学校に通いました
[音楽]
皆さん思っておられると思うのでもう言っ
てしまいますが料理屋のボンボンですはい
でちょっと違ったのはですね中学校高校は
大阪に通いましたで大学と大学院は東京で
一人暮らしをしました
両親はですね積極的に私を
京都から出そう出そうとしました
京都中辛と外からと両方から見る経験をし
ないとこの京都を変えていく人間になれ
ないというようなそういうような思いが
あったんじゃないかなと思います
土地によって人々の考え方も変わりますし
その狭い範囲の常識にとらわれる必要が
ないということを
身をもって体感して欲しかったのかなと今
となっては思います
僕と
母ですで
母ですね時に厳しいんですけども本当に
優しい母でした私の成績がですね多少
悪かろうが多少
遅刻しようがですねちょっとあの皆さんも
思い当たる方おられるんじゃないかと思う
んですけども全然
起こりませんでしたでまず私の言い分を
必ず聞いてくれましたで頭ごなしに叱られ
た記憶っていうのはほとんどありませんで
も本当に2回だけ2回だけ記憶に残る
ぐらい本当に恐ろしいことめちゃくちゃに
怒られたことがあります
1回目はですね私が
漫画週刊誌を買ってきた時のことでした
中学生の時です
繁華街にあったとある大きな大型書店で私
がその漫画週刊誌を買って帰ってきます
すると母はそんなどこでも買える雑誌を何
でわざわざその大型書店で買うてくるの
もっと考え
大文と優しめに再現しましたが
本当に
恐ろしい
人だったんですねはいっていう感じにもう
そのぐらい怒られました
恐ろしい迫力でしたで最後に今はもう閉店
したんですけれども
隣の長男にあった町のいわゆる小さな書店
でこれからは買うようにとそういうふうに
言いました
2回目は高校3年生の時でした
今から25年前のこと25年ほど前ですね
ごめんなさい
大学受験の
願書に
貼り付ける証明写真
今だとあのデジタルデータで送信して
しまうんですけども私の時代は本当の
証明写真を
印刷して貼り付けなければいけませんでし
たのでそれをこう取ってきた時のことです
数学の最寄り駅にですねそれをこう取る
写真機が設置されていたんですねで私とし
ては安いしで枚数もいっぱいもらえるしで
待たずにすぐもらえる本当にこう今まで
だったら現像してもらってすごく時間が
かかったのはすぐもらえるもう本当にいい
ことばっかりやんと思って学校の帰りに
友達と
軽い気持ちで取ってきましたするとまた母
は叱るんです
あんたなその写真機が家にご飯食べに来て
くれはると思う
かもっと
考え今すぐ取り直してって言って言うん
です
でこちらもですね今はもう店閉じられて
しまいましたが近所にあった写真館での
撮り直しを私に命じました
この2つのエピソード私に何を伝えていた
と
いたでしょうか一つはですね当たり前なん
ですけれどもこの世界は誰かの仕事ででき
ているということ
必ず誰かの仕事でできています2つ目は
あっけなく
街の景色を変えるほど人々の消費っていう
ものの行為が持ってるパワーそれは本当に
大きいそういうことではないかなと思い
ます
価格だとか
利便性そういったものに流されて自らの
消費行動を決めるこれは自覚なく少しずつ
自らの首を絞めること
母は私に中学生高校生といえども自分の
消費が世の中を変える可能性があ
るっていうことを強く意識させていました
日本でも選挙権を持つ年齢が18歳に
引き下げられました選挙に行こうという
こと叫ばれますでも18歳よりずっと前
私たちはお小遣いもらった時からその
すでに社会を変えるインパクトのある武器
をこの手に持ってるんだと思います
さてここからですねコロナで一変して
しまった話をします皆さんもご存知の通り
我々飲食店の置かれている環境というのは
この2年あまりこの中の影響でまさに本当
に一変してしまいました
営業時間が制限されたりお酒の提供が制限
されたり
座席数を
減らすことを求められたり
収支の計画っていうのはあらゆるお店で
大きく
崩壊しました
私もお店に来てもらえない以上
持ち帰りの拡大にチャレンジすることにし
ました
ただお店のお料理をそのまま
持ち帰りの容器に
詰めるのではなくて少し工夫をしました
ちょっとずっと出てましたけれどもこんな
写真の感じ
お料理をですね全て同じサイズの容器に
入れてこんな風にですねお客様に
木に組み合わせて
購入してもらう仕組みです
お客様の評判も非常に良いものでした
するとまた私は思いついてしまいます
これこの大きさの容器に入ってたらうちの
料理だけじゃなくて他のお店のお料理も
一緒に組み合わせて販売することできる
よう
な実は私のお店っていうのはもともと40
年ぐらい前からデパ地下での販売を行って
いましたそこでの経験を蓄積していました
のでこういう変化にも柔軟に対応すること
ができました
でも同じこの中に喘ぐ飲食店の中にはそう
したご経験がなく苦しんでおられるお店
さんも多いことを知りました
実は一般の方ご存知の方少ないと思います
が
元々作ってすぐ食べてもらえるお料理と
作り終えて
販売されるお料理
召し上がるまでが時間が非常に長いお料理
これは製造過程の取り扱いに大きな違いが
あるんです
でまたこれってですね2つもしくは4つの
お料理を入れられる箱があってそこに何を
入れるかは自由選ぶのは自分次第お客様が
自分だけの納得する1食を作ってもらえる
例えばですねお年をお召しの方がお子様
ランチみたいな組み合わせの一食を作って
もらってもいいし逆にお子様が本当に激渋
の和食全開みたいな一色作ってもらっても
いい
他人に
迷惑をかけない限り自分さえ納得してれば
いいので自分の好きな物っていうのは
もっと追求していいんじゃないかなと私は
常々思っています
多様性を備えた社会っていうのは自分の
好きなものそれを追求した後にそれを
認め合うことができる人々によって作ら
れるのかなと
そしてそれを表現した今までにない商品に
なるんじゃないかなとそう考えましたまた
極端な話ですね私のお店だけが変化して
生き残ってもダメで
京都には町に目指したたくさんの様々な
個性のあるお店さんがたくさんあります
和食だってありますし中華も洋食もこう
いうたくさんの選択肢がある状況だから
こそ私の店を選んで来てくださるお客様も
ある
地域のその食の多様性を守るためにも今は
お店が一つ点と点で
いるのではなくてですね点が線になって線
がさらに
面になって
魅力を発信していかなくてはいけないので
はないかなとそういうふうに考えました
競い合う競争から共に作る
競争への
転換です
幸いなことにですね私の思いに共感して
くださった地域金融機関それと百貨店さん
また地域のたくさんのお店さんがこの試み
に協力をしてくださいましたでこの春一つ
の売り場を作ることができました
本当に成功も
失敗もあって本当に
課題もたくさん出てきましたけども
担当業者に進むということはなかったん
ですけども私まだ一つ大きな発見をしまし
た
それは
成功と失敗は
紙一重だということです
それは
失敗するよりも成功した方がいいんです
けれども
成功からは地震が得られますでも逆に
失敗からも
経験が得られます
思ってて何にもやらないより
失敗したって
挑戦したことはせえへんかったことよりも
はるかに素晴らしいことでした
さてそろそろ閉めないといけません最後に
もう一つ大事な話をします
それは見落としがちなんですけれどもこの
チャレンジの土台になったものの話です
それは
冒頭にも申し上げました人と人との
つながりのことです
皆さんはですね学校や職場それと家それが
に自分の居場所っていうのはお持ち
でしょうか
最近の言葉ではサードプレイスという風に
も言われるそうです本当にたまたまですが
私は地域コミュニティの中にそういう
居場所を見つけていました
そこで私がこういう思いがあってこういう
ものを作ってみたい
これまあみんなのためになるんちゃうかな
いやでもそうでもないんかなとか本当に
思い悩みました
思い悩んでそのコミュニティの皆さんに
話してみました言いふらしてみました
そしたらですねそれは面白い」って背中
押してくれる人とか一緒にやろうって言っ
てくださる方実現のためのアイディア
くださる方人と人をつないでくださる方
だんだん勝手に人の輪が大きくなりました
それらの人がおられなければ私の思いつ
きってのは本当にただの思いつきなんです
絶対に形になることはないんです
アイデアを思いついた私が偉いんじゃなく
てこんな変なこと思いついてそれを許容し
てくれる
京都の
町と人が持ってるその包容力の大きさこれ
こそが偉大なんじゃないのかなと思いまし
た
今はですねさらにそのコミュニティから
機能は仲間で新たなグループも作ったり
作って全員が若手の経営者の集まりを作っ
たり製造
業資料小売業サービス業いろんな業種の
ほぼみんな社長というのそういうグループ
も作りました
今はそれぞれ
経験を生かして思いや志のある若者とか
学生さんにその思いが形になるまでを
支援させてもらう活動を始めようかななど
と
夢のような話をしています
そういう集まりとかつながりサード
プレイスですねそこで何ができるかどんな
価値を生み出せるか本当に何もわからない
んですけれどもそれでもワクワクしながら
この
冒険と実験これを続ければいいかなと私は
思っています
若い方はですね
周りに気軽に話しかけてみればいいんです
ちゃんとしないといけないとかちゃんと
話さないといけないとかそんなこと全く
思わなくていいです
ほんの少しですね
勇気を出して自分の考えてることそれを
背伸びしないで話す
自分をさらけ出すっていうのは本当に
勇気がいるんですでも人と人のつながりと
いうのは
全てその小さな
勇気から始まります
私は
働くって何かを作ることだと思っています
でも最近作るものが変わってきました
もともと料理人っていうのは料理を作る
仕事だと思っていました
そうじゃないんです料理人っていうのは
食べてもらったお客様の明日の
元気な体を作るんです
そう考えるとですね私も私が作るものは
ですねもう料理に限る必要はなくなりまし
た
若者が明日への勇気を持ってるような社会
を作る
このことでも
このことも料理人の仕事に含めていいん
じゃないのかなと思いましたなので今日話
を聞いてなんかわからんけど
元気出たなとか思う方が本当にこの会場に
一人でもおられたら私はこの料理人として
いい仕事をさせてもらったなと思います
これで私のお話はおしまいになります皆様
ご清聴いただきありがとうございました
[拍手]